when i first joined metallica i it's
funny because i didn't really
realize how difficult
it might be because you know various
bands that i was in we did press we did
interviews we did all this stuff but it
was never on the level of metallica you
know what i mean it was like
yeah like you know 20 times more than i
ever you know just
and you kind of adjust to that mindset
it's like okay
all right it's time to get to work you
know
do you recall what your reaction was the
first time
that you uh got wind that you guys would
be collaborating with the san francisco
symphony
uh symphony yeah um actually we were on
tour
uh we had um for hardwired our last
record we uh
we toured pretty extensively
like it was spread out but i mean we're
talking over two years of
touring and at some point
just a few months before it seemed like
it was this great opportunity they're
opening the san francisco chase center
um yes the new i guess say basketball
arena for the golden state warriors as
well as
celebrating the san francisco symphony
and then the 20-year anniversary of
s m one you know which was the show they
had done
um uh would have been just over 20 years
ago
i wasn't involved in that one but it was
uh
it was kind of like the stars aligned so
um
it just seemed like it was something
that we could do but it wasn't
originally in the schedule it wasn't
like
this thing was planned two years ago it
wasn't it came together
a little bit later and so it was slotted
right there
at a time when we could do it and it
just worked out
so it was it was great and
now looking now looking back it ended up
being our last show
of the tour cycle you know wasn't we
were supposed to have 20 more shows
um you know in uh south
america uh you know more u.s states
and uh and then i guess yeah so the
grand finale was s
m2 for us yeah but what an amazing way
to do it like
40 000 people attended this thing was it
like
what kind of energy do you get from that
number of people
well it's it's it's that number of
people but spread over two shows
and uh it's a big venue it's it's a huge
venue it's indoor
um but you know we were just playing in
europe to
80 000 people you know it started the
france and over 80 000 people
and you know you had 60 000 i think in
poland it was like
it was kind of strange because the
numbers in europe were huge
and that's not i know it's you know you
you're told so often
in the music business that rock and
metal
it's it's dead or it's dying and i'm
just like
i mean i always take it as it comes but
i'm there i'm standing on these stages
at
olympic stadium in munich and i played
there a few times whether it was with
metallica
or you know um back in the day with
suicidal tendencies opening for guns and
roses
or you know i me maybe with ozzy but i
never seen the studies the stadium that
packed you know the
all of these stadiums were were packed
you know on another level than what i
ever imagined so i'm just thinking
myself
how are we able to still do this on this
level it's just it's kind of
interesting but um you know
you see young people out there older
people it's just
really mixed and um you know
it seems like the audience has expanded
and groaned
um so getting into san francisco to do
the chase center gig which was literally
within a week
from playing in manheim germany
it was a different experience because it
was indoors but like you said it was a
lot of people i was more moved by the
fact that
we're playing with you know like a 80
piece
orchestra and there's this wall of sound
from that experience and then beyond
that you've got the crowd
and they're more than anything you
realize that they're experiencing
something new too
so you could feel that inertia you know
what they're feeling and the excitement
and um and that's a very powerful thing
you know just
it's hard to explain it's like the magic
carpet you know and you're just riding
on this
sound this wall of sound this it's
pretty cool
it's funny uh to me like the idea of
people that would go well
you know a symphony orchestra and
metallica i don't
see it but metallica's music is so
dramatic there's so much drama
already built in so many levels of sound
and story that go into them and that
that to me kind of goes hand in hand
with what a lot of classical music is
like
so how does that orchestra you were
trying to describe it just a second ago
but how does that orchestra and how does
that sound and enhance what you guys are
already doing
well here's the thing um
if you listen to a lot of metallica's
music
our music really kind of is
is really built on in a lot of ways it's
built on that style of arranging and the
layers of harmonies and
and uh melodies um and then the
kind of the balance of the it's like
this this
journey that you take in the song you
know songs are pretty long a lot of the
times
there's even songs that we haven't
played with an orchestra yet that would
be
incredible with an orchestra song like
orion
or you know suicide redemption
is a really amazing song that has those
kind of layers
so there's there's still room i mean i
think it'll be an snm3
and have a whole nother batch of songs
i just think that um
i mean this is my opinion um early on uh
cliff burton
um you know he was the original
bass player uh who brought
this kind of uh ingredients into
the band early on in
help to bring those layers to life and
it's stuck with the band all this time
you know
um so uh it's just
i don't know some bands have that in
their music and some don't and metallica
we have that in our music
you know there's just a weird ingredient
that comes from the classical
universe and that's how it it just helps
you know
it really makes us strong with 80
to 100 you know orchestral players
yeah it's i've talked to other bands
that have been together for a long time
they tend to make this comparison
between like
being in a band and being in the
marriage right my dad always said
you know when you're going to get
married you want to be with someone who
is going to be easy for you to be with
at this point in time is it easy for you
guys to be together like what keeps
metallica such
united front and like we keep seeing you
guys come out
maybe maybe you take a couple of years
off but you come out with something
else really impressive and really
massive so what keeps it uh
[Music]
it's a good it's a good question um and
i and i find myself saying this
in in a lot of interviews recently and
maybe it has to do with the current
uh temperature of the universe and the
pandemic and everything
um you you've got to number one
be flexible and you've got to have an
understanding of the individuals that
you're
working with um and it's kind of like
it's your family so
you want to understand you know you
understand like you would understand
your brother or your sister or your
you know your kids or whatever and um
and you've got to be respectful of who
they are
and how they are and we are that way
with each other as a band
that's not easy to do because creative
people can be
uh complicated and challenging and
nobody's perfect
you know everybody's got their demons or
whatever you know issues you know
you just uh have to um understand the
personalities and for
me i've always been in bands where
somehow i end up
being in the middle of those
personalities and uh kind of the
you know i don't know if peacekeeper is
the right word but just
um kind of more of a go-to person that
has to sort of come up with
i don't know if it's solutions but you
know just you get in those situations
and
you know even with music you know
somehow with when this band
you know there are times where i think
they count on me or they rely on me
to ask about a certain part of a song
and it's sometimes it's a song they
wrote you know it's not even a song i
wrote so it's like
uh well that would be almost all the
songs so but
um there's a level of trust in your band
members
and um you know
i've i've been in situations
where i've you know be between ozzy
osbourne
and suicidal tendencies and you know
working with jerry cantrell from alice
in chains
uh making the solo record with him that
we had done
20 years ago you know you learn
about who you're with and um
you know a lot of times some of your
best musicians on the planet
have a weird complexity you know and you
just have to understand it i mean we
worked with lou reed
and it was an incredible experience but
at the same time
lou could be complicated but you just
had to understand
that that's who he is that's how he
works and
he's very passionate about his music and
his point of view and everything
so you want to be flexible to that
because in that you can grow and you can
learn something from that person so i
feel i'm always learning from my
bandmates
and it's like like with kirk for
instance our guitar player i've been
learning more about him
in the last two three years than and
then in the 17
i mean i've been in the band for 17
years but 14 years prior
to that you know i i did i didn't
really know i knew he could play and i
knew things about his playing but then
i'm all of a sudden i'm like wow he's
really really good or he's really
knowledgeable or he loves jazz or he
you know we're similar and that we both
like soul music or
you know r b whatever or classic you
know 70s stuff
so you know it's it's you know and you
create a bond and a new friendship
and a level of trust so it's important
just to
have that flexibility and to you know
it's it's one thing that you got you got
to be able to play i mean that's just
goes without saying but it's another
challenge when you got to know the
people
and how they tick and and be you know be
there for them
yeah you guys have been always really
good at like you say
being flexible and being able to adapt
because the music industry changes so
much
and it's changed so much in like the 17
years that you've been with
metallica so now with this this latest
change that we're in i mean you
you said it yourself just a minute ago s
m two was
the finale but there were supposed to be
more like there was supposed to be more
uh shows so what does metallica show
look like
moving forward how are you guys going to
adapt to or how have you been adapting
even
to what we're all going through right
now well yeah um
you know we again yeah we would have had
20 more shows not snm
shows but we would have had 20 more um
shows around the world
um with with our you know support of
this
this not i say recent release but again
it was
already two years um
[Music]
you know it's kind of like what we did
recently we
uh we performed a show with no crowd but
it's for
a drive-in show i'm sure you've heard of
the drive-in shows that they're doing so
all across north america i guess it's
around 300 drive-in theaters
um you know they will experience this
and it it's it's you know i mean it's
not like it's really been done very
often
so it's something new but uh
it's us being uh how do you say like
kind of trying something
uh and adapting to this situation
as best as we can but in that process
you know like
i was saying we had to create a bubble
similar to the nba and what they've done
you know on a smaller scale but we had
to create this kind of
sanitized environment taking multiple
tests and
and everything so that we could just get
together to perform you know without a
crowd
so it's involved and it takes a
commitment but
what's important excuse me is our crowd
our crowd our our team our
detects and our sound crew and
even though it's a smaller crew right
now everybody has sort of that same
mindset
so even just the band itself with
us as musicians we still need the
support of our
of our crew and our family that also
have the same kind of work ethic
and we've been fortunate and blessed to
have people that
work with us that respect us and
and are there to do the best they can
and
and um as far as touring goes you know i
mean we're all in the same boat we just
don't know when we'll be able to get in
front of a real audience officially
and uh until then we just try to
uh you know take the necessary steps to
do what we can do and um
you know we'll see how that blossoms the
i guess the good news for us is we're
really trying to focus on on our
creativity and working on new ideas new
music so that
you know when all of this sort of kind
of
hopefully settles in we can get back out
and
support a new record we don't
one of the things about this band is we
don't have a shortage of ideas we got
so many ideas and riffs and
it's never been a problem for metallica
i know it becomes a
problem for a lot of bands at a certain
age and point in
their careers it's hard to write songs
it's you know you lose a little bit of
the hunger and the desire you don't have
as many ideas that is not the case for
us
something we got too many ideas you know
right on man hey thank you so much for
the time um
and this snapchat's wild it's awesome
thank you
thank you yeah it was a lot of fun and
uh
you know maybe 10 years from now we'll
do snm3 but uh
again we're concentrating on new ideas
new music and
um yeah hopefully we'll see you all
in person are you in canada i'm in
canada yeah okay
cool yeah well we love canada so
hopefully we'll be up there playing live
some new songs all right